hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game uh between robert james
fischer and svetos argliego rich
i was uh planning on having a rest day
today but then i figured
why not why not better show a game
played uh well
by bobby fisher because we haven't seen
a game uh by bobby for quite some time
now ever since i did the bobby fischer
saga we pretty much uh don't show any
more games
by bobby fischer even though he has a
lot of great games that we still haven't
covered
which is something that i plan to
rectify uh maybe maybe sometimes uh
sometime in the future so uh without
further ado let's check it out uh
this game uh took place in the
tournament of peace that took place in
uh ravine and zagreb in 1970 so
basically right before
uh fischer started his uh path to
conquer the chess world
at you know the in interstellar
tournament of palmer america the the
candidates matches and of course the
final match against the boris posky
uh and here upon arriving here uh he
already requested an additional thousand
dollars to even participate in this
tournament because
uh fischer arrived from herzegovi he
played the blitz tournament there and he
finished uh four and a half points
against mikhail tal and also
five points ahead of victor courtney so
that's
really insane and wayne came here i
thought uh
he thought that he would you know get
some more money because they would be
honored
that uh he's playing there uh but they
denied his request and then
bobby refused to play in the first round
as you know
something fisher very often did but then
uh parma
his opponent in the first round said
that the the russians are very happy
that you are not playing bobby
uh so you know they take that into
consideration and upon hearing this
as the story goes bob decided to play
so uh we've discussed the results of
this tournament very often but we
haven't really checked out any of the
games here aside from fisher's only loss
in the tournament to kovachovich
which is basically his uh only loss uh
well he's the last loss before
uh starting the the interzonal
tournament of palma de mallorca
so uh without further ado let's check it
out it's quite an interesting
game and uh well uh that's uh
that's all i'm gonna say and uh yeah uh
upon hearing
this that the the russians will be happy
that fischer will not play
uh he only replied true uh okay let's
play
so let's see how fisher uh decided to
open with the white pieces as usual
fisher the e4 player opens with e4
uh gligorich opens with e5 we have
knight to f3 knight to c6 and the bishop
to b5 the rule lopez is on the board
uh we have a6 the glee gorge goes for
morphy's defense and the bishop to a4
with knight to f6 and castle so just a
normal
uh normal line that's being played today
very often
uh bishop to e7 rook to e1 and b5
chasing away bobby's bishop bishop to b3
and
now d6 and here c3 so these are all very
standard moves that are played even
today in top tier tournaments we have
castles
uh and now h3 and here we have h6
something called
the dismissal of defense uh we have d4
bobby strikes in the center and now
rook to e8 preparing to shift the bishop
to f8 again this is still all played
today we have knight beat to d2 with the
standard maneuver of shifting the knight
over to f1 and then to g3
and bishop to f8 now by uh svetozar we
have
knight to f1 uh and here bishop to b7
here a bit more popular is bishop to d7
but
both moves are very popular we have
bishop to b7 by gligoric
and now knight the g3 fischer eyeing
that
f5 square and now knight to a5 a
standard idea
in the royal lopez attacking the bishop
on b3 and preparing to strike one
once more in the center with c5 so
bishop back to c2
not knight to c4 putting some pressure
on white's position
and now b3 here chasing away the knight
knight to b6 and
now a4 of course now that the target has
been created here on b5 bobby attacks it
uh and here nowadays as this is all
still being played today b captures on
a4 is the go to move but uh gligorich in
those days
played c5 uh so what do you play here
with d5 by bobby closing the center and
now
even c4 you can always capture on a4 but
glee guruji decided against this he
played c4
and b4 now leaving black one more chance
to capture on a4
otherwise bobby is most likely going to
push the pawn all the way to a5
and have a nicely closed center and the
queen side and then he's going to take
the game over to the king's side
so well you could capture here uh maybe
not something
or that's all that great uh you could
capture with the knight but
just capturing with the pawn runs into
bishop to e3
and now this knight is coming to d2 you
will put additional pressure on the c4
pawn and then
these two pawns are weak so black has uh
uh
not the greatest of positions so instead
after b4
bishop backed the c8 by gligorich and
now uh bishop to e3
just continuing development we have
bishop to d7 and now a5
bobby closes off the queen side and
attacks that knight pushes it away
uh we have knight to c8 and now just
queen to d2 putting pressure on the
king's side
and now bobby needs to figure out a way
how to continue
uh this attack as veto star would most
likely be very glad
uh with with a draw against bobby with
the black pieces so here
knights to h7 now you're ready to push
that uh
f5 pawn if ever needed uh with king to
h2 and
now bishop to e7 uh we have knight to f5
asking now do you want to capture on f5
and the black can indeed do this but
after captures captures
white doesn't mind the the double def
pawn he's gonna play
g4 uh uh cement his uh pawn on f5 and
then just
enjoy a very very comfortable position
and black always have to watch out for
ideas like bishop captures what if what
if this diagonal opens up and so on
so here uh after this knight to f5 by
fischer we have bishop to g5 by
gligorich
and now comes knight cactus and g5 we
have h captures on g5 and
now g4 and if you haven't captured the
knight on f5 then you definitely don't
capture it now because here bobby would
just play g
captures he would get a nice uh a
semi-open file for his rooks he would
bring the other rook to the g
file and the attack would simply keep
mounting on so here
after g4 we have g6 agligorich now
pushes the knight away
and knight back to g3 uh we have f6 now
strengthening the position here and it
seems like
black defended there is nothing to worry
about however there is one little thing
to worry about
and that is what happens if bobby places
uh his rooks
on the h file and this is exactly what
bobby does he plays
rook to h1 now he's going to move the
king and even if needed you can even
double up rooks on the h file before you
continue
uh with the push of the h pawn so here
rook to f8
you want to play rook f7 move the knight
and then bring the rook to h7 to help
out
counter that rook on h1 so king g2
and now uh we have rook to f7 uh bobby
first
one first has to play f3 if you play
with h4 right away then the g
pawn is hanging so just f3 defending
that pawn
knights to f8 and only now h4 so here
bobby opens up the h file uh on the next
move we have g
captures rook captures and now rook to
h7 offering a trade of rooks but now
just rook h8h1 and it's a
very very uh difficult position for
black to play because
like i said the queen side is closed the
king side is closed you you don't have a
breakthrough of any sort with black
and you there's simply no way for you to
bring your pieces into the game so here
after
this doubling of the rooks we have rook
capture some h4
uh rook captures on h4 and the g5 and
now with the g5 lego reach closed off
the dark square bishop along uh with
the light square bishop so it seems uh
bobby's attack uh
has stopped however we have rooked the
h5 by fischer
and now this is an incredibly difficult
position for glycogen to play
i'm just going to demonstrate what
happens if if gligorich plays
something so let's say he goes knight to
h7
fischer's plan is to just bust open
through the position with f4 even
at the price of some material for
example if g captures bishop captures
and now you you've uh you know you've
created a breakthrough and there's
nothing black can
do about this if the bishop is captured
it doesn't help
queen captures and now what do you play
here uh this bishop
this bishop's diagonal is opening up the
knight is also coming into the game
so we might see something like queen e7
knight to h5 going now after the f6 pawn
and if queen to e5 trying to get some
sort of a queen trade in
now we just go for rook to g6 check king
f8 and now our king hunt begins queen h6
check king e7 you're gonna capture on h7
with check king
to d8 and now knight captures on f6
threatening checkmate so black has to
react there's really not much you can do
here
and after let's say rookie seven
defending this you're gonna go rook g8
to check and now of course you cannot go
here because the queen
can capture once again so you go you're
gonna block with the bishop but now
queen f5 and that's it there is no
defense uh
if you trade queens you're just losing
because you're down material
and if you don't uh if you don't trade
queens uh well
what else are you playing uh uh
because once you capture the queen first
rook captures here comes
with check and only after the king moves
you capture the queen e captures on f5
and now it's just game over
but other than this there's really
really not
much for you to do here uh you you
cannot
capture the queen you cannot move the
queen otherwise this is happening
so this would was not possible so after
this rook to h6
ligo rich was struggling to find the
move i don't know the exact situation on
the clock but i imagine he was somewhat
low on time
most likely and he played king to g7 he
attacked bobby's rook
and said all right move your rook and
then we continue the game if you play
knight to f5 i'm just going to capture
it not a problem
however he missed one very important
idea here
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for bobby while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
the only move that wins here and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
rook captures on f6 this is what bobby
played and it was in this position i
know 35 that sweatshirt
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
uh why not well if king captures them
bishop captures and g5 just wins the
queen
and if you don't capture with the king
if you capture with the queen
now bishop a knight stage 5 check again
just wins the queen king knows you're
gonna capture the queen and that's
that's just game black has really no
compensation
to continue this whatsoever so uh that
doesn't work
capturing with that doesn't work uh so
what can you do
uh instead of uh capturing well you
could not capture but
then you i mean your entire position
just falls apart knight is coming to h5
bishop captures on g5
and so on so of course uh gligorich
knows this and he of course decided
not to continue uh and another excellent
victory for bobby fischer who
if you've ever heard me talk about this
tournament of peace in uh that took
place in romanian zagreb
will be crushed uh crushed to the field
uh but i am going to show you here one
very important image now this is a an
image that was taken
prior to the final round so here you can
see fisher uh
exchanging some words with with lego
reach his opponent in this game so let's
just
enjoy that photo for a second as we
don't have many of them but
some photos of of this tournament do
exist so
here's one nice one and also here are
the final standings of the tournament
we've showed them a few times already
but just in case you're new to the
channel
uh there we have it fisher won the
tournament with
13 points uh so two whole points ahead
of
uh last year vasily smith
so really crushed the field and then of
course you have
petrossian mini chief of berto
brown
so 18 players were in this tournament
but bobby just uh
as usual reigns supreme which is not uh
not surprising as
this was the time where bobby fischer
was the strongest he crushed everyone in
the herzeg blitz uh in
in herzegovi blitz tournament then he
came at the determinant of peace also
crushed everyone with a with a two-point
lead and then he announced that he's
going after the crown that he will
challenge the russians
and so on which you probably know if
you've watched my bobby fischer saga if
you haven't uh do check it out
i will put a link into it in the
description below so you can start
increasing your vast knowledge uh so
yeah
uh interestingly uh bobby received uh a
special trophy after winning this
tournament it's called
the horseman of peace now i couldn't
find a photo of this uh
of this uh well trophy the horsemen of
peace but you know i do have
an image in my mind of how i imagine it
to look
and it's it's quite a beautiful trophy
if any of you maybe have
an image of this trophy or something i
would very much enjoy seeing that
uh so you know do share it and then we
can you know share it share it with
everyone
but it does sound very mysterious the
horsemen of peace
uh but yeah so fischer announced that
and they said that uh
upon returning fischer left it at the us
embassy so
maybe it's still uh still somewhere
around there
uh but yeah uh so uh that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it
and uh yeah we might show some other
games but
at some point i would like to really
cover all of this because we've covered
the entire bobby fischer saga but then
maybe these two tournaments to cover
them in in its entirety
would uh serve as a nice mini bobby
fischer saga that could kind of lead
into the fischer saga so sort of a
prequel
uh so maybe if you guys are interested
in that as well we we can check out um
how those games went as you can see uh
all top theory that's played
even today even though it was played
some 50 years ago and it still stands uh
so yeah
i once again hope you guys enjoyed it uh
i would like to thank a mystery person
uh scott steinerman's dad uh aaron
anderson and marco armando serderooch
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day